Donnie
if you're seeing this I just want you to
know I'm sorry we're both sorry we
didn't know how could we
but just know we get it now we get it
sort of
okay don't panic don't panic
Dalida prey will no longer be a nuisance
to us after my associates picked him up
at gunpoint from the airport they
dropped him off in the middle of the
woods where nobody can find him let's
just say that the troubling nature of
demo him and Donnie Despres will no
longer be on our radars dude what's
wrong with you what you kidnapped a man
at gunpoint and left him to die
that's fucking messed up he was
threatening our operation guy we're
sweet filmmakers we remake films badly
we're not the goddamn Mafia are you a
psycho but-but-but dude I don't even
want to look at you the less I'm
associated with this the better yeah I'm
off to be an Internet reviewer they're
mentally stable wait wait where are you
going does this mean you won't be at the
Christmas party oh ouch
the health
Rebecca you alive
no oh me too I can't feel my legs
where are you on your legs
what happened all I remember is the
sweet actors guild scream when went
after you
wait where's Quinn gonna join it you
mean in the bathroom why are you in the
toilet
why is your shirt say Malkovich equals
balls why are you dressed as Belle from
Beauty in the beasts what in the hell
happened here
please tell me nothing I do with dad
well I've gathered all the footage I
could find from the past three days yeah
we've been out for that long
typical Irish hangover yeah some coffee
oh thank you all right Oh is there
whiskey in this yeah it's Irish coffee
are you kidding me Harry the dog we've
had enough dog Thanks and you don't need
caffeine all right we have here Schmidt
your pie all right
well everything for starters there's
this oh you don't look as good without
your dress Shh
Donny if you're seeing this I just want
you to know I'm sorry we didn't know how
could we but just know we get it now we
get it sort of what the hell does that
mean I don't know but then there's this
lissa Hoffman and James what the hell
are these people do you know what James
no you know you only friend I know by
that name is Jamison and that's you're
dedicating a film to the bottle well
it's about time somebody did
so what's after that a movie a movie
that we made when did we make a movie I
don't know but we need context from here
on out we're doing things by the book
we're gonna go back to the beginning and
figure out how we got here then maybe we
can figure out the biggest mystery of
them all
what's that it's been three days where's
Donnie Quinn come and see ins got to be
us
Quinn I swear to God if you are drinking
without me I will find you and Stella as
you faster Sam
so be it Quinn then I come back your
balls are mine conjure the answering
machine Carl called nearly three days
ago why did he say no reception was
piss-poor
something about Bob Barker's balls
Germans and we have no choice we need to
go and order and see what happened did
you guys hear that
Rebecca for you
I'm Fabrizio I work here who are you to
call me it's okay
it's the tenant I'm Rebecca your
security guard
oh yeah the stunad hey what are you
doing with a butcher's knife I was
uh making marinara sauce this late I'm a
hungry man see we were defending
ourselves against a group of angry
psychos and about to get drunk to numb
the pain if you'd like to join us
yeah sure won't be the first time I've
heard that often ok ok
directors log timecode zero more numbers
are adding up I'm not gonna bother to
but to keep you updated anyway I seem to
be abandoned in the middle of the woods
here um
no doubt obviously the swag bastards I
don't exactly know what to do I'm not
really survivalist but uh one thing I do
know about is film so I've been saying
to myself what would the Blair Witch
Project do and then just do the exact
opposite of that because those kids were
fucking idiots
ok so the first thing those kids from
the Blair Witch Project did is that they
got lost for ten seconds and they panic
so I am NOT gonna panic which is easier
said than done but after having myself a
good cry actually maybe any another one
ok better but the good news is that I'm
so deep inside the forest that chances
are nothing dangerous could hear me and
dragged me down and
do whatever he's probably gonna do oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god wait
here look at here we got a bottle people
a bottle okay you know what that means
that means civilization there's people
out here okay I'm gonna read us even get
some more information
ah let's see uh Army of Northern
Virginia Confederate States of America I
don't think that's a good song
I only over beckoned to come our doing
okay without me yeah come on come on Oh
started started yeah all right that is
why you never play drunk and truth or
dare with me
damn girl yeah I've never seen a no.9
which one drink so much it's all two I
can't do caffeine but liquor you will be
my bitch by the way Febreze this
marinara sauce it's delicious that's
because the secret is in the meat what
kind of meat is it skal Eddie says some
kind of pork no that's a still not on
55th Street Irwin keep his mouth shut
now I'm kidding the secrets in the
oregano Oh meatball
oh god no well at least we know who that
guy is keep going let's see what else
happened that night right so I've spent
the last four hours trying to build a
fire by rubbing two sticks together uh
found out doesn't really work when
everything is so wet
I only saw work once on Pawn Stars
Chumlee tried it was pretty funny you
want a bet not so funny trying to keep
cool by the light on your cell phone
stupid energy-saver come on my fingers
are do nothing to keep turn you back on
hello oh hey I'm lost kik can you hear
me yeah god I hope that's a female
okay so obviously if I'm gonna be out
here for a bit I need food I need to eat
so I've taken a bunch of acorns and a
leaves on a dug a little hole and just
set a little trap for a little woodland
friend it might be one a Ridge
I'm not telling a camera fish got him oh
okay so interesting thing about
squirrels I'll apparently they're
natural jumpers and I don't mean like
you know open it just out of the hole I
mean like Luke Skywalker Empire Strikes
Back in the carbon features like show me
and I meet just like unbelievable but
it's okay cuz you know I tracked it he's
not gonna go away from me a easy okay so
I tracked in this tree and I imagine if
I can just find a way to climb up the
tree you know I heard squirrels are
poisonous I'm not get this truth or dare
yeah I was uh I think that means truth
okay
Oh what was your first sexual experience
well I was camping with uncle friends
yeah dear okay so I a spooked a possum
and he appears to be playing dead now
here's the thing I don't know if playing
dead means like he's just acting he's
gonna like spring on me and try to
attack me or I thought I heard somewhere
that they play dead so much that like
they'll play dead until they are dead
like they just won't move I'm gonna take
a chance
I mean chances are the first one is it
right anyway yeah the first one was
correct
apparently when they're playing dead
they are just playing dead waiting to
strike with teeth rows filled with
shark-like teeth but the plus side to
that is that apparently they're no match
for a shoe yes just never they come and
shoot swagged against their furry little
skull seems to be their kryptonite so
yeah uh he's not gonna be bothering me
anytime soon Rebecca Tacoma if you can
hear this I want you to give the eulogy
at my funeral no doubt you were the only
people concerned when I was missing
can't breathe
she had it there before
it's like sick the Soleil accept - the
evil french-canadians yeah well now it's
your turn breezy oh you got to do that
magic after you we're talking about fine
fine just give me a minute to set up
I'll bet guy you're a lots more talented
than I previously thought yeah well I
I'm not as dumb as you guys all think
that I am I never said that you were
dumb oh I can tell everybody thinks that
about me III don't for one night no it's
okay it's okay like it's not your fault
anyone who first meets me really thinks
that and then they don't get a chance to
actually see if I can do anything or
have opinions er I think it's just an
actress then people just assume that
because you're going into the world of
acting you I think it's an easy out well
yeah but I mean you'd think that talent
would be something that mattered when
you're trying to get cast but it really
it does it like if you're pretty that's
great if you're dumb that's even better
because then you don't have an opinion
or you don't have an idea of how you
want to do the blowing of actresses who
aren't traditionally attractive look at
Kathy Bates character actress she plays
psychos and smarmy bitches yeah but in
that About Schmidt
she took a top off and did you see it
no why because she took a top off
exactly all right how about Judi Dench
she's British she could read out to the
phonebook and it would sound credible
867 double-oh-seven okay then what about
Meryl Streep Margaret Thatcher Julia
Child skeletor's lover from Bridges of
Madison County shrews cartoons Cougars
and milfs oh all right Cameron Diaz in
Being John Malkovich they didn't make
her look hot in there oh yeah let's take
the hot chick and make her look frumpy
brilliant she can get any role she wants
do you know how many normal ugly people
would kill for that role but no let's
hand it to the cute one and praise her
for being edgy
huh that's what 40 means in Hollywood
Tacoma I'm 23
that means I'm at my midlife crisis how
sad is that
well I'm the plus side it's not like
your careers going anywhere anytime soon
so oh well I mean that was really stupid
to say wasn't it this is the part where
you go after if I turn your testicles
into bangers and mash is anything you
say not a stereotype go hey we doing
this a what Oh fantastic well at least
it isn't that creepy a little girl it's
okay there's no such thing as ghosts as
I keep telling myself there's no such
thing as ghosts
now such thing as ghosts no such thing
as ghosts no such thing as
Oh